today on the matt will show the latest
on the murder of five infants by an
abortionist serial killer in dc it's a
story that the corporate media the local
government federal government has
decided to completely ignore but we're
not also judge jackson is confirmed as
the first black woman supreme court
justice and also the first supreme court
justice who can't define the word woman
a historic in case occasion indeed plus
mainstream media journalists hold a
seminar on disinformation but things
don't go as they planned during the q a
portion and american airlines has an
exciting new aviation invention buses in
our daily cancellation what the hell is
a biromantic asexual it's the latest
lgbt innovation and it of course makes
no sense at all we'll talk about all
that and more today on the matt wall
show
[Music]
are you a member of the taliban and
unaware of it some people on the left
have been saying that pro-life people in
texas and the ever-growing number of
states with a heartbeat act are no
better than the taliban no science or
biology or acknowledgement that
heartbeats are actually a good thing
just you against us and therefore you're
the taliban and that's the response this
is what they're that's what the left of
course is saying and this is why our
friends at 40 days for life wrote the
number to amazon christian bestseller
what to say when the complete new guide
to discussing abortion how to change
minds and convert hearts in a brave new
world 40 days for life is based in texas
and is one of the largest pro-life
grassroots organizations in the world
with a million volunteers in a thousand
cities in 64 countries holding peaceful
40-day vigils outside of abortion
facilities to save lives and help
abortion workers who have a change of
heart leave their jobs get the book what
to say when
i wrote the forward for it so you know
that at least that part of the good in
fact the entire book is great it covers
the old arguments and the new ones that
you'll hear at work or with family so
get it and check out
40daysforlife.com to help end abortion
where you live today
so perhaps you've heard about the story
of the fox in dc not fox the tv network
but an actual fox with rabies it turns
out she had taken up residence on
capitol hill had been terrorizing the
local inhabitants for days
finally the rabbit fox attacked and bit
a democratic congressman and a
journalist and this was the last straw
the police were sent in to find and
arrest the insurrectionist canine and
after was apprehended the fox was
euthanized and the peace was restored to
the land now personally
as you know i'm not much of an animal
rights guy but given that this animal
was attacking politicians and
journalists
i think it should have been set free and
promptly awarded a medal for its service
to the nation if anything more rabid
animals should be let loose in the
capital send some wolves in grizzlies
let the chips fall where they may and if
they devour everybody and seize control
of the government
i'm not sure we'd be in any worse shape
at the end of it in fact i think it'd be
a quite an improvement
in any case i bring this up because this
was by the measure of media coverage
one of the top stories in washington
this week
every major news outlet published
multiple stories about the fox
the washington post especially followed
the saga of the bloodthirsty fox all
week cnn npr the new york times many
other outlets also kept track of the
story as well posting multiple breaking
news bulletins concerning it
meanwhile though elsewhere in dc
another saga has been unfolding which
has attracted far less interest from the
corporate media
you might say this other story happening
in the same city right in our nation's
capital
is quite a bit more important than a fox
you'd say that anyway if you have a soul
and a brain which i suppose rules out
most of the people working in corporate
media
i'm referring of course to the just
uncovered murder of five infants at a dc
abortion clinic now you've heard me talk
about this all week because it is one of
the most important things happening in
our country right now the cover-up has
made the story far less visible but it
also makes it all the more important
um you know if you want to know the
things that we should be talking about
and you should be paying attention to
just look for the things that they don't
want you to pay attention to so to
review briefly last week a pro-life
group in dc called progressive
anti-abortion uprising obtained a box of
quote medical waste from a clinic in the
city run by a monstrous psychopath named
cesar santangelo
uh the box was given to them by a driver
from a company called curtis bay energy
which operates out of baltimore and
we'll get back to curtis bay
in just a moment because they're an
important piece of this story
as for the boxes as we've covered on the
show they contain the remains of well
over 100 aborted babies five of those
babies were fully developed late-term
infant children
well past the point of quote-unquote
viability
there was ample evidence from the
injuries on their bodies and from their
stage of development that these babies
were killed either in illegal partial
birth abortions or in illegal post-birth
abortions
otherwise known as infanticide
but the d.c police still refused to
investigate the crime they refused to do
an autopsy
the mayor has so far not acknowledged
the case at all
she's just ignoring it as the media is
mostly ignoring it and the bite
administration is ignoring it
and as they hope you ignore it
now following the latest updates in the
case yesterday the daily wire had a
report showing that cesar santangelo
was caught on video during a live-action
undercover investigation in 2012
admitting explicitly
that if any baby is born alive during an
abortion he will leave them to die
let's go back and listen to that again
you see this 23 24 weeks if you're you
know extra
if you if you do everything possible to
help it survive
you know there's maybe a 20 to 30
percent chance that it would survive
if you don't do anything
then you know the chances are much much
less kind of like you're so scared
you know like would you mean you would
you make sure that it like yeah it
doesn't you know there's other things
you do obviously you're here for a
certain procedure and if your your
pregnancy were let's say you went into
labor the membranes ruptured and you
delivered before we got to the
determination part of the procedure here
you know then we would do things we
would we would not help her
we wouldn't think we wouldn't uh
intubate
okay okay see you in nature yeah we
wouldn't do any extra you know it's like
uh yeah it would be you know a person
that would be a terminal person in the
in in the hospital
having cancer you know you wouldn't do
any extra procedures to help that person
survive
like
now he says we do the same things here
not we would do the same thing
but we do the same things
and what are those things well uh if it
was hard to understand this conversation
let's recap santangelo is assuring the
mother who's really an undercover
journalist
that if her baby which he refers to as
it
if the it were to survive the abortion
he could he would just leave the child
to die
he would make sure that it does not
survive
he compares this to a terminal cancer
patient in the hospital except of course
the terminal cancer patient cannot be
helped
there's there's nothing that can be done
to help the terminal cancer patient
survive their condition that's why we
call it terminal
they can at least be given painkillers
though something that the baby during an
abortion is not given
i mean you can't make any attempt to
ease the child's pain and suffering
because only living beings feel pain and
feel suffering so to give the child
painkillers would be to admit that he is
a living being which the abortionist
murderer cannot do
but the other big difference obviously
is that the child born alive
can be helped
he just needs some basic life-saving
medical interventions in order to live
he has refused those interventions
through no choice or consent of his own
that's not like the cancer patient let's
bring it back to the patient in the
hospital imagine that you had a patient
in a hospital
experiencing a medical emergency
and there is something very simple that
could be done to save his life
but instead the doctors
put him off in the corner and watch him
die that's what santangelo is saying he
would do and does do
and now there's physical evidence
that he takes even a more direct role in
the child's death than that
what we're describing here is already
murder leaving the baby to die that's
murder you're killing the baby
but the babies recovered from the
medical waste box were not simply left
to die they were killed their skulls
were crushed their brains were sucked
out of their head
this is happening here in america while
the media talks about a dead fox
and what about that medical waste box
where was it headed well it was headed
to curtis bay
which is the company whose name is on
the box where the bodies were recovered
from
and that company says on its website
that it is quote the only facility in
the northeast region that utilizes waste
to energy incineration to safely convert
infectious biomedical waste and
non-hazardous pharmaceuticals into
useful energy
that's right on the website
so they were going to burn the
children's bodies for electricity
the baltimore area is apparently at
least partially being powered by the
bodies of dead children
right there on the website
now curtis bay denies this for the
record they say that uh they don't burn
quote unquote fetal remains for energy
and yet their name is on the box
what's more they collect medical waste
evidently from abortion clinics what
else would be inside the box
and whatever curtis bay knew about the
contents of its own boxes
i think we can fairly assume that they
knew what was inside the box because
again you're collecting from an abortion
clinic
now maybe they never check so they have
plausible deniability that could very
well be the case
a don't ask don't tell kind of situation
where they send the boxes over to
santangelo and they say oh send us your
medical waste and by the way we don't
take fetal remains
hint wink kind of thing
but whatever they knew
santangelo certainly knew it was in the
boxes
just as planned parenthood was caught
selling the parts of aborted babies for
scientific research santangelo was
apparently selling them off to be burned
for fuel
and that brings us to the latest one of
our reporters mary margaret olahan who
was she's been doing great work on this
story and so many other stories before
this she went to the clinic to get some
answers about all this the clinic in dc
where santangelo operates
while she was there
she got a fair bit more than she
expected or bargained for after trying
to speak to santangelo and being shut
down olahan left the building and
happened across a it happened across a
visibly pregnant woman in clear distress
who was right then in the process of
undergoing an abortion
the woman was in severe pain and told
our reporter that quote they just took
the tubes out and olehan explains what
that means reading now from the article
it says i immediately understood her to
mean laminaria sticks often made out of
seaweed which abortionists use to dilate
a woman's cervix dr ingrid scop a senior
fellow and director of medical affairs
at the pro-life charlotte louisiana
institute tells me that the laminaria
absorbs the water from the cervix and
helps the cervix to dilate making it
easier for the abortionist to reach in
to the uterus to blindly with surgical
instruments remove the baby in a
piecemeal fashion
in a dilation and evacuation
dismemberment abortion
former abortionist kathy ultman now an
associate scholar with the charlotte
loziere institute told me it's likely
that the young woman i encountered would
be heading into an induction abortion
since she was in the hallway
if she were going to be having a
dilation evacuation abortion
altman said the doctor would take the
laminaria out at the beginning of the
procedure while she was in the stirrups
in an induction abortion the doctor
usually injects the baby with
digoxin or potassium chloride when he
puts the laminaria in then waits a day
or two for the baby to die before
inducing the abortion
but the baby does not always die altman
told me and if the doctor does not reach
in and cut the umbilical cord before the
baby is induced
that baby could be born alive
so the laminaria sticks are used either
for abortions where the baby is ripped
apart and dismembered piece by piece
again with no painkillers nothing at all
being done for the pain
so this child will feel the pain of
being ripped apart
or um as was probably the case for this
woman that our reporter encountered
they're using an abortion where the baby
is stabbed with a poisoned needle and
left to die over the course of one or
two days
if the child is not dead by then he'll
be born alive potentially and either
killed directly or left off in the
corner of the room
to continue his agonizingly slow death
now by the way um
lila rose at live action took a look at
the google reviews of this clinic
earlier in the week
and found several women who just right
there in the reviews
said that they underwent the same sort
of procedure and they report that their
babies were either born alive or may
have been born alive one woman says that
uh her baby was born
and then her delivered and then rushed
out of the room and she asked
if the baby was alive and was not given
a straight answer
this is all very common
it happens all the time
at clinics all over the country
babies that are being born dismembered
ripped apart this is all happening all
across the country especially in places
like dc
and then we find out
in some cases reportedly
being shipped off to power plants to be
burned for fuel
i mean we are burning our children for
fuel
and the people who brag the most about
their compassion
about their love for the downtrodden
and especially for the most vulnerable
they are the ones
facilitating this
and sitting off on the sidelines and
watching
and applauding
as it happens
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
um all right
so
judge kentangi jackson was confirmed
yesterday is now officially the first
black
female supreme court justice and so we
heard quite a lot yesterday about the
historic
nature this historic occasion
including a dick durbin democratic
lawmaker who had a lot to say about how
historic this is and how wonderful it is
we should all be celebrating let's
listen to a little bit of that
i'd like to close with one last personal
plea to my senate colleagues
i hope you'll think about this
in the years to come
long after we've left the senate
one of our grandchildren may ask where
we were on this historic day
april 7 2022
when america broke down what seemed like
an impossible racial barrier and voted
to send the first african-american woman
to serve on our highest court
i will be proud to say i was on the
senate floor
standing at my desk and casting my vote
with pride
for the next associate justice of the
supreme court of the united states
justice katanji brown jackson
i hope my colleagues will join me in
sharing this historic moment
you know what i take away from that he
says uh long after we've left the senate
when is that gonna be exactly can we get
can we get on with that i mean this
guy's six thousand years old and he's
still in the senate talking about long
after we're gone many years from now
that's the most troubling thing here
many years from now after we're all gone
meanwhile the the average age in the
senate is 97
and many years from now they'll be gone
how about now why why don't you go home
now and start telling your grandchildren
all these incredible stories
that you're so proud about um rafael
warnock
uh also was he got a little bit
spiritual in this in this moment and uh
let's hear a bit of that
yes i'm a senator
i'm a pastor
but beyond all of that
i'm the father of a young black girl
i know how much it means
for judge jackson
to have navigated the double jeopardy of
racism and sexism to now stand in the
glory of this moment
in all of her excellence
for my five-year-old daughter
and for so many young women in our
country
but really if we're thinking about it
right for all of us
seeing judge jackson ascend to the
supreme court reflects the promise of
progress on which our democracy rests
so what a great day it is in america
a great day in america well a couple of
things here first of all we we they want
us to celebrate
a moment like this and there are several
reasons that we can't actually celebrate
the moment we'll go through some of them
the first reason is that she's not a
good candidate
um that um
she is you know we should celebrate no
matter what they look like or what uh
sex they are what skin color they have
we should celebrate supreme court
justice who actually are faithful to the
constitution and will interpret the
constitution and try to defend the
constitution because that is their job
to uphold the law as it is written in
the constitution we know that that is
not
what jackson is going to do so there's
nothing really here to celebrate the
other reason we can't celebrate it is it
is that we hear people like warnock that
this is it's a it's a moment of progress
it's progress it's the same thing we
heard
uh what feels like ancient history now
when barack obama was first elected i
mean how much do we hear about this is
this is a moment of incredible progress
and a black man's been elected president
and they tell us that and between obama
and jackson there have been many other
such moments of alleged glass ceilings
breaking all over the place and yet they
say this progress is happening
in one breath and then the next breath
they revert back to just we're still a
systemically racist country it's just as
bad now as it was during slavery times
i mean we had we had jon stewart
yesterday talking about the three-fifths
compromises as if nothing has changed
since then
he said the american dream is a is false
it's a myth it doesn't exist yeah well
this is a black woman is now supreme
court justice
being hailed by a black senator
on the floor of the senate
is is that not evidence
is she enjoying the american dream so
apparently it is possible
so they say that this is that this is a
sign of progress
and i could almost put everything else
aside
if they actually meant it
like i wish i could say to them okay
it's progress great so can we can we
move on now
are are you are you saying that we now
have progressed past the point of
systemic racism we're not that kind of
country anymore
is that what you're saying
no i think this progress happened a long
time ago but if you're saying that it
happened right now then
okay
but what happens the next day when
you're pretending that um
this is a systemically racist country
and all the rest of it
so they want to celebrate the progress
in one moment and then in the next very
next moment they want to pretend that no
progress has happened at all
in fact even in saying this
he gives away the game because he says
that kantanji jackson had to navigate
the double jeopardy of racism and sexism
yeah that's one way of looking at it
or another way of looking at it is that
kantanji jackson's success is yet more
evidence
that this systemic racism and sexism
actually doesn't exist
but it's an unfalsifiable claim
that's the thing about systemic
institutional racism and sexism it is
unfalsifiable literally nothing can
happen
that would be evidence that it doesn't
exist
even a black man being elected president
becoming the most powerful man in the
free world
was not evidence at all that systemic
racism doesn't exist
you could have you could have not only
the most powerful man in our government
be a black man but you could have
um an administration comprised of racial
minorities and still is not evidence
if you don't believe me just the next
time you hear someone going on about
about systemic racism just ask them
what would need to happen
to prove to you
that systemic racism in america doesn't
exist what would you need to see happen
because we know a black man being
elected president isn't going to do it
um we know that a black female supreme
court justice that's not going to do it
okay that doesn't do it what would do it
for you what do you need to see
and i'll tell you right now they won't
be able to tell
you and that is
indication right there that is proof
that you have an unfalsifiable claim and
unfalsifiable claims are fallacious
it can't be falsified because it also
can't be proven it's it's this it's a
thing that exists out in the ether it
doesn't exist in reality
you know it's it's like you can't you
can't you can't falsify the existence of
unicorns you can't prove that unicorns
don't exist
um
and uh let's see what else we got what
one other i thought this was this was
this was actually inspiring camilla
harris we've heard from some of the
centers but camila harris also had
something to say obviously about this
historic moment and uh let's listen to
her thoughts such as they are
you know there's so much about what's
happening in the world now
that is presenting some of the worst
of
this moment and human
behaviors and then we have a moment like
this
that i think reminds us that there is
still so much yet to accomplish and that
we can accomplish
um
there's so much about what's happening
in the world now that is presenting some
of the worst of this moment and human
behaviors
let me okay there's so much about what's
happening in the world now
i understand that part
that is presenting some of the worst of
this moment
what's happening in the world is
presenting the worst of this moment
and human behaviors
she recovered by the end i'll give her
credit you know by by the end like in
the the first sentence was a mess uh the
second sentence she kind of recovered
and she had something approaching a
coherent thought so that's that's
progress you know that's progress from
from uh camille harris's progress from
the obama administration so
maybe there is there is hope yet there
is there is a chance for some kind of
progress
um
but no this is uh for all the reasons
described this cannot be considered a
historic moment also
because of course
they want us to celebrate
the first black woman
on the supreme court
but we don't know what a woman is what
do you mean by that
and this is a point
you know my fear with this with this
point
is that we will just we'll get tired of
saying it
and kind of move on but we have to don't
don't make that mistake
you got to hit him with this
every single opportunity every time i
mean every time anybody on the left
says anything about women
especially wants us to celebrate the
achievement of a woman or of women
generally every time they do it
you come right back with what do you
mean by that who is that what's a woman
what are you talking about define the
word
can just hit him over the head with it
bash him over the head with it
metaphorically
every chance you get
because this is not like a a meme or
just some kind of sassy fun comeback
this is a legitimate point a point that
destroys their entire world view that
they have to answer
and so we should never tire of bringing
it up
all right let's move to this so this
week the atlantic hosted a seminar at
the university of chicago called
disinformation and the erosion of
democracy where a whole bunch of
high-profile people in media and
politics to include obama apparently was
there
and they showed up to talk about the
dangers of disinformation
even though these are the purveyors of
disinformation
and this was a fact not lost on some in
the audience who were college kids
and during the q a portions they had the
chance to call the propagandist to task
in some really glorious video footage we
can't play all this but i want to play a
few a few a few clips here so first
here's a student
asking i think the first question that
comes to mind i mean you're having this
disinformation seminar and you were the
people who claim that the hunter biden
laptop was disinformation turns out that
that claim was disinformation how do you
rectify all that so here's a student
asking an atlantic journalist about um
this problem
thank you for doing this really
appreciate it i'm daniel schmidt i'm a
freshman at the university of chicago my
question is for miss applebaum so in
2020 you wrote those who live outside
the fox news bubble do not of course
need to learn any of this stuff about
hunter biden referring to his laptop of
curse
a poll later after that found that if
voters knew about the content of the
laptop sixteen percent of joe biden
voters would have acted differently now
of course we know a few weeks ago the
new york times confirmed that the
content is real do you think the media
acted inappropriately when they
instantly dismissed uh hunter biden's
laptop as russian disinformation and
what can we learn from that and ensuring
that what we label as this information
is truly this information and not
reality
my problem with hunter biden's laptop is
i think totally irrelevant i mean it's
not whether it's disinformation or i
mean i don't think the
hunter biden's um
business relationships have anything to
do with who should be president of the
united states so
i i didn't find i don't find it to be
interesting i mean that that would be my
problem with that as a major news story
oh it's not it's not interesting it just
just doesn't interest me that's all i
don't find it interesting
is that is that how we're deciding now
what news is worthy to be printed
if it's if it's interesting or not to
you personally
subjectively
during a during a presidential campaign
we're making decisions based on what you
personally find interesting
and if you don't find it interesting
then not only are we not going to talk
about it but it's going to be banned
from social media
that's that's a great power i mean i'd
love to have that power just ban
everything from social media that i
don't find interesting which would be
like 99.9 of the stuff on it
um not interesting she says but that of
course is not
what they were saying two years ago they
were not saying that it's not
interesting they were saying that it's
false that it's uh that it's
disinformation
so the next day this happened a couple
days ago the next day jonah goldberg
who's the token conservative on the
panel
um
responded to this bit about the uh and
he's also someone by the way who said
that this was all disinformation and a
lie in the hooks and everything and he
responded and has had his thoughts about
it let's listen to that
talk about a to c
they now think that if only the media
had told us about the laptop at the time
as the kid yesterday was suggesting
which i don't buy his
you know theory
that trump would have won you know but
for the censoring of the new york post
trump would have won
and it's i think it's a preposterous
counterfactual
but it's also
it's impossible for me to refute in the
same way i cannot refute that this
bottle is keeping all the polar bears
away
right um i mean do you see any polar
bears right i cannot i cannot prove the
negative and um and this is just it has
now become can we lock the doors just
it is it has been wrapped into
a much larger narrative and
um and so when they hear disinformation
they say oh you mean like hunter laptop
which actually turned out to be true
it's actually interior it's sickening to
listen to these smarmy
loudzika boots are keeping the polar
bears away that's not the point jonah
you know that's not the point
the point isn't isn't whether or not
it's true that it would have swayed the
election one way or another
look i i actually i
i myself am skeptical that the hunter
biden laptop story would have swayed the
election
could have
i'm skeptical of that what i said that
at the time when this when this story
came out and conservatives and and
right-wing media were hammering on the
hunter biden laptop thing right as we
were heading into the election
and uh now i didn't say that it's
disinformation and it should be banned
from social media i said like i i it's
true but
i don't think that this is the best
closing argument i don't think the best
closing argument against biden is that
his son is a scumbag and yeah you can
draw the connection between his son and
biden and you can draw these connections
and they are connected but that's a it's
a
it's if you want a political scandal to
land it has to be pretty simple and easy
to explain
and to connect the dots between hunter
biden's laptop and joe biden himself
that takes a couple more moves and it
just it's it's um
it's a harder case to make especially in
the closing weeks of a campaign you want
to go things that are much simpler and
more to the point about joe biden
himself because a lot of people they're
going to hear about
hunter's laptop well it turns out a lot
of people didn't hear about it because
it was censored by the media but i think
a lot of people would hear about it and
say well yeah i don't care what does
have to do with joe biden yeah his son
his grown son is a scumbag okay
um
again there is a connection there but
drawing the getting people to see the
connection
is a different matter it's not it's not
it's not the same thing right
um i think the stronger argument and the
closing argument against biden all along
should be about him and how incompetent
he is and also
his age and i know that his age came up
a lot but i think that should have been
the headline that should have been the
number one thing
hammering on the entire time this man is
losing his mind he's not fit for office
he's 78 years old he's got he's seen all
he has dementia yeah it was talked about
plenty but in my mind that's the number
one
most salient thing in the election to
bring up okay
um
but
that's that's academic that's that's
irrelevant
the fact is we don't know whether it
would have swayed the election because
it was censored
and all that matters whether or not it
would have or or wouldn't have not the
point
the point is
that the powers that be in the culture
the media
big tech they thought that it would
which is why they censored it
so this was an attempt to rig and sway
the election
not just an attempt it was they were
rigging
and they were rigging the election
that's it
now how do you quantify
the the effect that it had when you you
can't because you're speaking in in the
in theoretical and theoretical terms to
know for sure you have to go back in
time and do it all over again but
without without censoring that material
we can't do that so we can only speak
theoretically but this was a rigging of
the election that happened because
big tech and the media they thought
that this could be damning enough to
convince people to vote to either just
not vote for biden at all or to actually
vote for trump
and they were having flashbacks to the
email scandal with hillary clinton in
2016 which absolutely did
absolutely was one of the deciding
factors and
as well it ought to have been
leading to her losing and trump winning
so they were having flashbacks and they
said we cannot we can't let this happen
again
and so we're going to censor this
material
jonah goldberg is missing the point on
purpose
talking about in theory well what would
have happened that's not it they thought
that it would and they tried to censor
it and they did censor it because of
that
and that's the point
and it is it is
uh
it should infuriate you especially if
you pretend to care so much about
democracy and you're always accusing
trump and
the far right of waging an assault on
democracy
well how is this not an assault on
democracy
when there is
factual
and relevant
information about a political candidate
in a presidential election
that is kept from public view
because of how it might
sway them
how is that not an assault on democracy
um
let's see
okay i want to i want to get to this we
don't have a lot of time but we talked
yesterday about the case of um
maria lucille who is the woman who's on
death row right now
for brutally murdering her two-year-old
daughter
and she has had um
celebrities come out in her defense uh
you know just the the peanut gallery's
out in her defense
and a lot of this was
a lot of this began with a netflix
documentary
as is so often the case now
you've got these supposed true crime
netflix documentaries and these things
by the way these true
supposed true crime netflix
documentaries they are they are a
scourge on this planet at this point
um
so many examples of people watching
these quote unquote documentaries and
coming away thinking they understand a
case when really they don't understand
it at all i mean it all you know making
a murderer is one of the classic
examples of this of course still to this
day
people walk around saying that stephen
avery is uh has been unjudged freed from
prison
well i'll tell you what if they ever do
freedom from prison um and especially if
you're a woman and he moves in your
neighborhood
move out
because this guy is a murderous
psychopath and we know in that in that
quote-unquote documentary
um they left out a lot of relevant
information and that's the problem with
these documentaries
is that it's very easy to take a murder
case
and make a guilty person seem innocent
by simply just leaving out all the stuff
that makes them seem guilty real easy to
do
you just take the defense whatever the
defense is and you present that in film
form and you leave out all of the most
damning evidence and then people watch
that and they don't do any research on
their own and they walk away assuming
that oh this person's been thrown in
jail they don't belong there
in stephen avery's case it was uh i mean
there was so many things that were left
out just off the top of my head there's
the fact that his victim teresa halbach
uh you know she she uh was was going to
his house she had gone to his house a
couple times to take pictures for a
magazine of uh i think it was a
cars you know she was selling cars and
she she told her bosses that she doesn't
want to go back to his house because of
this guy the guy's a creep and would
show up to the door like in in with
nothing on but a bathrobe um
so she had already she'd already gotten
you know
um she was already freaked out by this
guy i didn't want to go there uh his his
dna
was found under the hood of her car
when he said he never went in her car
never was never no never wear anywhere
near it
um he had made plans earlier while he
was while he was in prison you know
years or years before talking about
torturing and raping
women um i mean he he he killed a cat
and they kind of mentioned that but they
downplayed he actually he doused a cat
and gasoline and set it on fire and this
is this is what like serial killers do
so all kinds of stuff like that left up
um similar thing with the maria lucille
case
um
and
we've heard about
family members of lucille who have come
to her defense
but apparently many of these are kids of
hers who are not living in the house
when all this happened because she had
like 12 kids i don't think all by the
same father
and um
and they've so they've been in and out
of foster care they were living in
different homes and so many of the kids
have come out in her defense and saying
she didn't do it they weren't in the
house at the time
one of her own daughters though who was
in the house has been on tick tock
speaking out and saying that her mom did
in fact viciously abuse her sister um
she didn't personally see some of the
worst abuse but she know she was in the
house and she knows that it was
happening so here she is on tick tock
talk about some of this let's play this
the only one who abused my sister was my
mother melissa lucio
no my father
step dad that lived in the house with us
was not aware of the abuse that was
going on
even us as kids we didn't know the
extent of the abuse that was happening
um we the abuse that we
talk about and know about is
the isolation of her keeping my sister
away from everyone not letting her play
with us
um
my mom would hold my sister down
on the bed or
she would hold her head down on the
pillow so that mariah wouldn't interact
with us
um we did see
my mom pinch mariah
but we never witnessed a punch we never
witnessed my mom bite mariah nor did we
ever witness my mom pull my sister's
hair but all of that was happening
um
like i said my dad was not aware of the
abuse he was always working
and the only time that i can think of
that the abuse was possibly happening
was
either when all of us were in school my
dad was working and my mom was alone
with mariah
or
when all of us were sleeping because
my mom slept or my mariah slept in the
bed with my mom and my dad
um
and that's the only thing that i can
think of
um we didn't see any of the abusing
until
when we came home or when my dad found
mariah that day in the bed um
mariah was soaked her her her pamper was
soaked and
my dad took off her clothes so that he
can change her pamper before the
ambulance got here or there
and um
when he took off her pamper of course he
had to take off her pants and that's
when he saw the bruises and
actually started screaming to my mom how
could he do that or how could she do
that and why was why did she abuse my
sister
so that's this woman's own child who's
reporting all this and now she's on
death row justly so for killing this
child says the child
fell down the steps
ali stuckey has a threat on this and and
has posted some of the court documents
detailing more about the abuse
that uh mariah the daughter suffered
um
at the hands of this disgusting woman
and she admits that she did she she okay
just reading and says appellant also
stated that she would hit mariah when
appellant got mad appellant also
described how she pinched mariah's
vagina and how she would sometimes grab
and squeeze mariah's arm palin described
how she bit mariah twice on the back at
different times about two weeks before
mariah's death appellant said that on
one occasion she bit mariah on the back
for no reason while she was combing
mariah's hair pelin said i just did it
appellan also stated that she would
spank mariah several times day after day
so
admitting to vicious like deranged
physical abuse of a child then the child
ends up dead with bruises and marks all
over her body says and and the claim is
that she fell down the steps
and people are buying this
it's like it's unthinkable to me and one
thing you hear a lot by the way is that
well the other kids said that they were
not personally abused
that doesn't mean anything
you know a parent an abusive psychotic
parent
kind of focusing their abuse on one
child is not uncommon
it happens a lot they have a name for
they call the cinderella phenomenon or a
target child selection and i don't
particularly like either of those terms
but those are the terms that are used
and this is something that that happens
it's a very well known phenomenon
where a parent abusive parent will
isolate for whatever reason will pick
one child isolate them we hear about
that in the video there how she was
isolated and then physically abused
while all the all the other kids are
left alone at least physically
that is clearly what happened here
this woman deserves to die
few people on earth deserve to die as
much as she does
and i will thank god when she is finally
executed because that's what she
deserves all right one other quick thing
before we get to the comment section a
report from a journalist that airline
weekly says
this is an exclusive report american
airlines is the latest offer an
on-the-ground alternative to flying amid
the pilot shortage in high oil prices
they will begin operating buses as
flights
for american from its uh philadelphia
airport hub in june
buses as flights is what they're calling
it in other words just you see it there
so no it's just a bus like unless the
bus flies
unless this is a magic school bus
situation where miss frizzle's flying it
through the air and going on adventures
it's not a bus as a flight it's just a
bus and so this is the innovation this
is the
the aviation innovation we're getting
now and i was thinking about this and it
just seems to me like we're moving
backwards right
because
30 years ago
you could take a supersonic flight from
new york to london in like three hours
three and a half hours
and um now if you're in philly and you
want to go to a city nearby that you buy
a plane ticket they put you on a bus
the the aviation industries is
progressing in the opposite direction
basically by 2030 american airlines
they'll be they'll be it'll be like
wright brothers planes they're flying
you'll be able to glide from new york
city to
another location in new york city that's
the direction we're heading
well if you're worried about not getting
enough of my wildly reasonable takes
before the coming alien invasion
mercifully wipes us out of our
collective misery then you need not fear
any longer that's because i've started a
weekly newsletter which will grace your
inbox once a week with some tips fun
facts updates and an introspective look
into the dark inner workings of my
disturbed terrifying mind and also the
occasional mean tweet you saw the
lengths i'm willing to go for abuela so
if you want to join them and get on my
side you'll head to dailywire.com matt
walsh report and subscribe to my
newsletter right now let's get to the
comment section
[Music]
memo type says is matt making an
institutional power argument yeah i am
making institutional power argument that
i have made many times for cancel
culture that's that is institutional
power is a real thing i guess you're
referring to the institutional power
argument we hear from the left where
they talk about how racism is defined by
institutional power and you can't be
racist unless you have institutional
power
and that's that's why only white people
can be racist yeah that's completely
bogus
for many reasons one is that racism has
nothing to do with institutional power
if you despise someone or judge them or
think they're inferior because of their
race then you're racist whether you have
institutional power or not it's also
false because white people are not the
only ones with institutional power but
um
that doesn't mean that
no argument should be made based on
institutional power institutional power
is a real thing that exists
and my argument is that although
although racism is not defined and
dependent upon institutional power
cancel culture is cancel culture that's
how you that's how you
distinguish between cancer culture and
just holding somebody accountable or
expressing your disapproval of something
or protesting
that's how you distinguish between those
two things because they're not the same
cancel culture is when the the the
powerful institutions in this country
are used against someone to shut them
down silence them
and it's done in a vengeful petty often
dishonest kind of way
for for ideological reasons like that's
what kev's culture is
i think we should be pretty
clear about that um
let's see
matt why aren't you displaying your
hard-earned trophy
yeah the trophy that somebody awarded me
for um you know dominating my children
in uh pickup basketball well the reason
i'm not displaying it is that the
shelving behind me the the the shelves
behind me are are fake because this
again as i've told you before it's just
a sheet it's a it's a
like a bench like a
bed sheet with an imprint of my old
studio on it so that's why i can't
unfortunately i can't display the trophy
speaking of which though
um speaking of me um
defeating my kids in various
competitions i did play as kind of a big
moment i played a
really was like the first time playing a
real board game against my kids it was
just my daughter the eight-year-old
julia
i played a monopoly so first time
playing monopoly against her and my wife
all three of us played and i just i
crushed their souls okay by the end of
this thing i i had every monopoly on the
board except for one
and it was just in total domination and
i told my daughter before him before we
we got into it i said i'm not gonna let
you win
we're playing for real now okay you're
eight years old we're playing a real
board game now and she said to me i i
know daddy i just want to play a game
with you i said okay let's play
and by the end of it i had one so
thoroughly of course she's and she
starts crying she's in tears
and i ask her like why are you crying
and she said she told me because she
thought she might win she got her hopes
up and i tried to comfort her and i said
no no jules you
you were never going to win i was always
going to win
you're not ever going to beat me in the
in this game or any other game and i
thought that would come for and
apparently didn't and my wife was
looking at me and
like i'm the bad guy all of a sudden
but i stand by this this is my dad
growing up we used to play cards and he
would never he would just he would never
let us win
he would ruin us in cards every single
time
and um
look how i turned out maybe not maybe
that doesn't help my case i don't know
um
and finally
aaron says matt i'm a correctional
officer who makes the inmates watch
their sweet daddy
well sweet daddy seems to like it could
have some troubling connotations in a
prison setting but
it is good to hear anyway i do
appreciate that i don't know how exactly
you force your does seem like that might
be a violation of human rights to force
your
inmates to listen to this podcast but i
appreciate it all the same
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
well disney is continuing its groveling
struggle sessions as its executives
debase themselves in ever more
extravagant and excruciating ways hoping
to win back the good favor of the lgbt
cabal that's really running the company
at this point
this week disney held another reimagined
tomorrow online seminar for its
employees and as always chris ruffo got
his hands on the footage we'll review
some of it but there's um there's one
part in particular that i'd like to pay
special attention to we'll get to that
in a couple minutes before we get there
here's a disney official announcing a
benefits program to help pay for sex
change surgeries for the children
of disney employees listen
the other big area is gender identity
and expression so doing all of this work
uh to ensure that our employees and cast
can express their gender here
authentically and proudly at the company
so you know coming up with guides on how
to change your photo information about
pronouns working with our benefits team
to give information about gender
affirmation procedures both for our
employees who are transitioning in trans
but also our employees who have kids who
are transitioning
gender affirmation procedure as you know
if you listen to the show is a euphemism
that in practice actually means chopping
the breasts off of teenage girls
chemically castrating young boys and
subjecting these confused and abused
children to various other forms of
medical savagery wasn't very long ago
that the left was still denying that
these kinds of things were done to
children at all
now though disney proudly announces that
it will foot the bill
for procedures that five seconds ago we
were told didn't exist weren't happening
will this be enough to satiate the
alphabet squad well of course not uh
during the same seminar various disney
employees and executives who claim
various different letters in the lgbt
xyz club appeared on camera to talk
about their deep and profound pain
this uh they them was feeling
particularly emotional let's listen to
that
you know for me
well one i'm an emotional person so
there's always a fear of crying in
public but i've just decided to accept
that this is who i am
um but in addition to that you know the
fact
just the fact of like how painful this
has been
and as a black person as a black queer
person as a black queer and trans person
you know to
do the work of holding the company
accountable means unpacking my own pain
for somebody else to learn
and
that is really hard to do
without knowing that it's going to get
better
and so if i'm going to continue to do
this and continue to show up and kind of
lay myself there for the benefit of my
colleagues and our leadership
i want to know
that
something is going to be done about it
so that i don't feel this way anymore
and so we don't feel this way anymore
as a black person as a black queer
person as a black queer trans person as
a black queer trans person with food
allergies as a black queer trans person
with food allergies and dyslexia as a
black queer trans person with food
allergies and syllexia and vertigo just
keep you know patting the victim resume
the woman insists that she's deeply in
pain she's suffering writhing and
emotional agony but as always she cannot
explain what exactly she's so upset
about
i think i know the answer one answer is
that she's a manipulative fraud who uses
emotional blackmail to control people
this of course is the number one most
common cherished tactic of lgbt
activists
the other is that she has an ego the
size of disney world but it's as thin
and fragile as it is over inflated and
she carries this massive bag of
narcissism around with her everywhere
and it's always getting you know bumped
into and bruised
this again is the classic story of lgbt
activists told over and over and over
again
you also notice how this woman has
almost no thoughts of her own everything
she utters is a talking point or
buzzword do the work unpack my pain
show up
she's so obsessed with herself and
focused on herself and yet there is
almost no self there she's a walking
talking leftist cliche
and we'll return to that theme in just a
moment but first
um we have to go to bob chapic who's the
disney ceo and a man who if he were any
more spineless would melt into a puddle
and disappear down the drain he's more
of a jellyfish than a man at this point
translucent insubstantial gelatinous
invertebrate
and apparently totally incapable of
experiencing shame watch
by now i hope you've all read my most
recent note in which i pledged to be a
better ally for the lgbtq plus community
apologize for not being the ally that
you needed me to be and committed to
ensuring that our company lives up to
its values
i meant every word
and that's what we're here to talk about
today
i know that we've got work to do and
that work starts with listening i'm glad
the company will hear from today's panel
of lgbtq plus employees
and i hope that you are as impacted as
i've been by the voices
that i've heard over the past few weeks
i've read many emails that have been
sent
spoken with lgbtq plus employees and
their allies met with advocacy groups
and convened my own leadership team
and i have been taken by the honesty the
openness and the urgency of their
stories i want you to know that your
words have made a real impact on me
i understand that we've made mistakes
and the pain that those mistakes have
caused and i know that our silence
wasn't just about the bill in florida
but about every time an individual or
institution that should have stood up
for this community did not
i and the leadership team are determined
to use this moment as a catalyst for
more meaningful and lasting change
you know it's in videos like this where
you really see the religious nature of
modern leftism chapit confesses his sins
seeks atonement and absolution i mean
every religion has this feature but in
say the christian religion the faithful
seek the forgiveness of our father who
art in heaven
chapic seeks the forgiveness of his own
gods who art in the lgbt initialism
there are many little demigods in that
club and everybody on the outside of the
club is struggling to get inside the
club and enjoy their own share of its
divinity a disney executive producer
named latoya ravenous has found her own
way into the club and uh it's pretty
interesting listen to this
i identify as like a biromantic asexual
i've had a lot
of
learning and growing about myself this
year kind of facilitated by how
comfortable i felt on
the proud family and with my immediate
team at disney tva and so it's just sort
of like
this creative dissonance between my
personal experience
a biromantic asexual
now let's break this down
an asexual is somebody who supposedly
doesn't experience any sexual attraction
at all to anyone the problem with that
identification is that first of all if
it's true that somebody experiences no
sexual attraction at all then it makes
absolutely no sense to include them in
the lgbt community given that this is a
community which is literally defined by
its various sexual attractions
putting an asexual person in the lgbt
camp it's like it's like having a club
for club for bird watchers and also
including people who have absolutely no
interest in bird watching
these are people who do not want to
partake in the very thing
that defines the club it makes no sense
to have them in the club in that case
also
people are not meant to be asexual and
are not asexual
now some animal species are asexual like
komodo dragons and certain species of
crayfish
but people are not komodo dragons or
crayfish
that woman as far as i can tell is
neither of those things she's a human
being
what we call asexuality would more
properly be characterized as a low
libido or a disinterest in romantic
relationships that's not the same thing
scientifically as asexuality
it is rather a dysfunction of the brain
which may be due to hormonal problems or
some sort of mental illness or trauma
suffered earlier in life you know it
could be a lot of reasons for it or
perhaps i think this is the most common
it could also be a symptom of spiritual
despair
some people have given up on human
relationships because they've decided
that they're not worth the cost or the
effort
but that's not asexuality
and whatever the cause of this
affliction it's not an identity
it's bizarre and self-limiting to find
your whole identity and your sexual
attraction but it's even more bizarre
and far more limiting to find your
identity in your lack of attraction
you are finding your sense your scent
yourself your sense of self
in the absence of something
this is no way to become a fully formed
and stable human being
but wait a second
she says that she's not only asexual but
also biromantic
but what does that mean
i mean in reality romantic means
something that is characterized by love
and affection towards another person
this is the dictionary definition
and we have to understand love in this
in this context
to be the erotic form of love
that's what romantic love is
that's why you would hopefully say that
you love your mother but you would even
more hopefully not say that you go you
go out to dinner with your mother it's a
romantic dinner
see there are different kinds of love
and romantic love is erotic love it's
sexual love
these are these are the same erotic
sexual romantic these are all synonyms
they belong in the same category
so how can somebody be romantic
more than that biromantic meaning that
they have romantic attraction to both
sexes and yet also at the same time be
asexual
well they can't is the answer
one of the latest lgbt innovations is to
draw this incoherent bifurcating line
between romantic and sexual
but the distinction just like the
distinction between sex and gender is
meaningless
romantic and sexual are the same thing
they are characterized the same way
if you're not romantically attracted to
somebody that you're not sexually
attracted to them if you are
romantically attracted to them you're
sexually attracted to them
there is no legible distinction between
the two
and yet the lgbt activists
draw one anyway
this is their game it never ends they
never stop their assault on language and
logic
all coherent concepts have to be broken
down torn to shreds
blended together and turned into a
jumbled smoothie of meaningless
contradictions
and that's why ultimately today we
thought i was going to cancel disney but
we already cancelled them so instead
in a much more specific sense we are
canceling biromantic asexuals can't
really be canceled i guess because they
don't exist but even so
cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great weekend godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo vadowsky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22. hey everybody this is andrew clavin
host of the andrew clavin show you know
some people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin